I applied to 17 schools I had a 4.2 GPA
and I only got into one and it was by
dream school which was NYU and after two
weeks I knew it wasn't for me I'm not
going to graduate from college in four
years with
$240,000 in debt and then do a job that
I don't even know if I'm going to like
yet so I was just like I'm out I'm
moving to La about a year and a half
into it I met Jake Paul at a camera shop
and he ended up following me on Twitter
and then he invited me over to the team
10 house at the time what do you say to
get him to follow you on Twitter I
actually up and I said Logan no
and now
and he was like it's Jake and I felt so
bad but I was like man congrats on like
everything you've done like seen you on
Vine and he was like oh what are you
doing here and I was like I'm a daily
blogger and he was like oh no way I'm on
day 50 and he was like what are you you
and I was like oh I'm on day like 530
and he was like what so it paid off I
was never in team 10 a lot of people
thought I was but I saw the success that
he had made through creating a Content
house and I just thought it was a great
concept so I just kind of adopted that
mentality when I started hype house